the three Muslims recently true Geordie
had some comments on Andrew Tate's
conversion to Islam meeting Andrew
come on Andrew Tate got God on his side
now there's no way Brian would win that
um although I would gladly blow myself
over if I could take that back with us
um that's the use of a stereotype there
which is obviously not what he uh I'm
just saying if he really wants to prove
it do the right thing
let's see how about that life you really
are yes although yeah not all Muslims
after me converting to Islam he made a
piece on one of his podcasts saying that
I'm not true in my conversion and then
insulted all Muslims then the Muslims
blow themselves up and I should go blow
myself up we should all blow ourselves
up making his comments about about an
entire religion as if that's somehow
funny
let me tell you something my friend and
if true Jordan if you're watching this
this is a message directly to you
there are certain times in life you need
to know when to shut the [ __ ] up
there are certain things which are not
funny certain things are not Beyond
reprisal you don't sit and insult a
man's religion just like you don't
insult a man's entire company and the
people who work for him that's one thing
but to insult my religion
and the religion of billions of people
across the planet making ignorant jokes
about [ __ ] blowing ourselves up
thinking that's going to go without
consequence You're Gonna Learn very
quickly my friend that was a mistake
she later on received a lot of backlash
he was dropped from different brands
like poker stars and the gym shark
and um before those dropping of the
brands even happened he released this
video uh and aims to apologize so let's
see what true Geordie had to say in his
retraction
[Music]
welcome back to the treasury podcast uh
so let's get straight into it I've
recently made a joke online
and it's caused the reaction upset
people are not happy with it so Millions
wanting to come on here talk about it
amongst ourselves we were on the stream
at the time that the joke was said by me
wasn't wasn't Lawrence's job was my joke
just to be absolutely clear just to sort
of give context for it uh
uh an old friend of mine uh we'll call
him Mr Potato Head for the sake of this
uh podcast because I know you'd be
desperate for me to say his name uh it
sounds trivial but it's not it's just
the way he is uh
he recently uh claimed to have uh joined
Islam now given some of his previous
statements that absolutely contradict
what a lot of Islam is about uh I
definitely uh didn't believe a lot of
what I was hearing from the internet uh
you know I made a joke in questioning
that Newfound faith of his that
conveniently comes at a time when he
needs as many supporters as he can get
it was a stupid joke as much as I don't
want to repeat the joke I think it's
only right so that people have context
they don't understand uh I said if he
really wants to prove he's a Muslim he
should blow himself up as soon as
something like that now when I when I
say that out loud when I'm when I'm
aware of it
horrendous you know it was one of those
off the cuff remarks that I made in a
with a total lack of thought and I used
uh an unrealistic stereotype to take aim
at someone who seriously dislikes me
obviously I don't believe that's what
Muslims actually do and I don't actually
want Mr Potato Head to die as much as I
don't really like them
um it was a very stupid thing to say it
was an idiotic joke uh one I'm sorry for
you know
you know I don't believe any religious
stereotype just to be clear whether it
be all pre-suppied or all Jewish people
run the world and are rich like they're
all as ridiculous as each other to me
and that was partly why I felt
comfortable in that moment in saying
something so ridiculous because I never
thought for one second that anyone would
take
offense to something so silly right you
know at the time I'm sat next to a guy
who has a Muslim family who knows how
much love I have for everyone like you
know I'm not a prejudiced guy or
whatever you want to call me is that
right Prejudice yeah
um and but now after like feeling out
the backlash and what people are saying
and I'm talking about the genuinely
upset people I know some people will
just use anything to try and take you
down and I get I've given them a golden
opportunity but I understand like some
people have had that thrown in their
face a lot and for me as much as it's
ridiculous and it's something that I
don't believe I understand that for them
some people had years of that being
inside to them you know and I really
wasn't thinking about that in that
moment so yeah uh all I can say is sorry
when I was sitting there I I guess when
I watched it back I was like oh maybe I
should have maybe I should have said
something there even just as a friend
just to be like oh you can't say that
but
the problem for you is you know me so
well bro if I flagged everything you
said every uh live stream we wouldn't
get a live stream done no but you get
what I mean yeah you you know and that's
the difference is you know
but they don't I know I know I get that
I know where you're coming from but I
think especially as a podcaster and I
think as people who um like at least we
are spotty who aspire to speak for a
living if maybe if you misspeak
sometimes or you say something that you
don't
fully understand at that point it's also
good to acknowledge that yeah I've got
people who I love and respect who are
Muslim who uh
who may see that and think oh
so that's how he thinks about us right
like this is like the real yeah all that
the faces slipped and it's like God like
I would hate for that you know um do you
ever consider I'm not I'm not trying to
put you to the sword here but do you
ever consider sort of like your own
biases and your own prejudices because
especially in my own marriage like I
think I've been forced to look at what
my biases and Prejudice is were against
Islam not I and I like went into a
marriage thinking I understood it in
that sense and I went into a long-term
relationship like that and actually I
didn't and actually I realized down the
years that a lot of what I thought was
either wrong or what you would call
bigoted to an extent where it was just
like it was a negative view of someone
that I had never questioned because it
always just felt very apparent to me and
that's where the like you know the whole
these people blow themselves up things
sometimes come from is because that is
what's reinforced to a lot of people and
that is that is unlike the tip of your
tongue sometimes because it's a it's a
sometimes it seems like a funny thing to
say
uh not for me that was like an
unrealistic way it felt hyperbolic well
yeah because what I'm trying to see is
Mr Potato Head shouldn't you know should
fall off unfortunately to say he should
pray five times a day doesn't quite have
the witty bitey joke that I was looking
for I am not questioning religion I was
simply making a joke at the time about
him and religion I understand that the
point is as I make ignorant jokes about
many different things on a daily basis
and I'm online at all times but certain
things are more sensitive to certain
people than others that's about to say
just cut it off bro yeah so
I want to hear your thoughts on that man
oh all right man so first off
I just want to say that
the apology doesn't seem sincere at all
and you know Allah knows best all knows
best what's in the hearts and if it was
sincere well then
this is what ego does to you
this is what ego does to you when you
can't humble yourself
when you can't humble yourself you end
up being humiliated and it's by your own
hands
if you can't step down then like you're
literally going to humiliate yourself
and I mean technically that's what he
did he can't he can't try to take that
back he can't try to say he was a joke
he can't try to say that it was
it wasn't a slur or something like that
like I'm sorry man but
you're saying that some people are
sensitive to it it's not the Muslims are
sensitive it's that we are an intolerant
of disrespect
of literally not even stepping on the
bound is like you pretty much just
you pretty much just shine bro and you
can go ahead and edit that out man but
I'm serious man like you can't you can't
come back from that bro and exactly like
Andrew take said just wait it's funny
because I believe he he posted this
apology first and then afterwards uh
regardless poker stars and Jim shark
dropped him
um uh as a as an ambassador for their
brand
so
and um
I have a bit of a I mean my take doesn't
differ too much because
I'm I'm not a dog Annie I could see as
well that there's a lot of a lot of it
just doesn't make sense a lot of it
seems staged a lot of it people are
saying like the video is monetized he
says like And subscribe at the end like
things like like it just really seems
like this is forced um and that he
doesn't really care very much
um and he has alternative uh alternative
motives but at the same time
I think there are some times where we're
pointing that stuff out and questioning
it is important
uh and I think it is good to mention it
in in a situation like this just so
people aren't confused but I actually
made my first response to this was
actually inviting him to Islam as well
and I know that sounds a bit funny or
whatever
but if you think about it the reason
he's in the situation is because he has
a lack of Standards he has a lack of
like where to draw the line in his life
right I think
Lawrence has a little bit more of a line
but that line I think is more dictated
by society and by people
um which means it's always going to
shift but going back to Jordy himself
he doesn't have a line
right there is no line that he was given
no line that he has that he knows not to
step over so as soon as he stepped over
that line he realized okay that's
pushing the boundaries I shouldn't do
that he tries to retract it but
obviously it's too late
and that's what I stand that's not Islam
does it gives you a boundary of where
not to cross
and we we know that certain boundaries
once you cross them there's no going
back
and um it's like you've already you've
already messed up you can't retract
whatever you've done or whatever you've
said and Islam stops you from doing
those things Islam gives you a solution
for life and I think that's why Andrew
Tay actually accepted Islam like he
mentioned because it has these
boundaries because Muslims are people
who actually enforce what they believe
they preach what they believe and a part
of preaching what we believe is is
preaching even people like Drew Jordy
people who you know a lot of Muslims
will quickly Sean and and turn away and
be like you know you're
whatever call them whatever I'm not
going to say any any rude terms here but
actually with these people we should
invite them to Islam because that's what
they're lacking in life they're lacking
God they're lacking a lot in their life
and Lawrence as well um he has a Muslim
family so it seems to be the case that
he grew up with a Muslim family that
maybe wasn't practicing the right way or
maybe enforced on him and pushed him
away later on Allahu Adam
but I'd like for the opportunity to be
able to talk to them give them dawa and
I think somebody should for real
um
I I know that's kind of a major like sub
point to the actual video itself but I
think what you said was was
explanatory enough
yeah maybe I came off a bit harsh you
know and it might even
it might even sound like
it was a threat on my end what was it
doing on education and I don't think
that's it at all
if you actually dig deeper like what I'm
saying it's not it's not that the
Muslims are going to do something to
this guy and Allah Allah like Allah
knows best right you might have one of
these Muslims who's like
yo like that's it right but I don't I'm
not I'm not trying to conclude to that
I'm saying like at the end of the day
like we have to answer to Allah we have
to answer to the Creator so even if all
the Muslims didn't do anything to you
for your entire life at the end
you have to answer to the Creator bro
yeah and if you're all right with that
and you're cool with that then
hey
and that's that's all I'm saying boys
you can't you can't you can't go back
from this
so to True Geordie
Allah says in the Quran
he says
uh and there's actually Noah peace be
upon him he says to his people
um
and basically say I see forgiveness from
Allah all right say forgiveness from God
indeed he is the most forgiving
then he says
he will basically like send blessings
from the heavens upon you
and he will bless you with children
uh and and so on and so forth they'll
bless you with having a bless you with
paradise and so on and so forth and all
you have to do is seek the Forgiveness
of God so Jordy all I want you to do all
I want you to do is ask Allah to forgive
you just ask the Creator to forgive you
and then humble yourself and truly
recognize listen I have beef right now
I'm fighting these people I'm fighting
this guide everyone hates me or no
whatever you're thinking
and know that you're gonna die one day
and you will die and they will die
everybody's gonna die one day
and then later on the day of judgment
everyone you guys are all going to
dispute about what you talked about on
Earth
right
you're all going to dispute we know that
for a fact that the day of judgment is
going to happen everyone's going to be
held accountable so do you want to live
a life and and die this this back and
forth of it's stepping over the line and
retracting step over the line retracting
it's useless man it's honestly useless
you will be so much more content when
you focus on the one who created you
when you focus on staying within the
boundaries and preaching that which
makes God happy and that is I think also
why Andrew take something this time he
realized it was the truth and now he has
a mission and that's why he's going he's
propagating Assam people like Aiden Ross
so I invite you to come do the same come
accept Islam the Muslims will back you
the Muslims will support you the Muslims
will take you under their wing the
Muslims will be there
to help you as a brother you will be our
brother in Islam look with Andrew Tate
you know he said something some things
in the past but as soon as he accepted
Islam we know as Muslims everything was
wiped away we forgive him for that
because Allah forgave him for that and
now we're taking him as a brother and we
have there are many brilliant Muslims
out there that are teaching him and
helping him grow in his religion and
adopt the truth fully and we invite you
to do the same insha Allah
made me feel like ass now bro I'm sorry
let me let me retract let me track what
I said that like
uh
that he can't take what he said back and
all that stuff which technically he
can't take it back it was what just said
but it's not to say that he can't be
forgiven because there's been people
who've done way worse things than what
this guy has done
so like yeah was that harsh yes was it
necessary yes
but also
we invite you to Islam but this is
this that's it man that's it I think I
think you said it better for me
though and with that being said